you'll tell a girl I am married or I
have a girlfriend I think okay so like
what no I agree that girls are just as
sleazy as dudes it's just oh oh yeah
it's just dudes are stupid yeah and
different about their sleeves sleeves is
[Applause]
brilliant and like know how they are
those are more so a little sneaky [ __ ]
and if it's animals in New York girls
are little rat girls are little rats
across the trainer pigeon and are
pigeons
that's right dude that's the male rats
with wings that's right and you just go
around pecking at stubborn dumbly doing
it but the rats are yeah girls are just
we can't catch you know girls are so
shady we actually talked about I know
this may not be as much as what you guys
are doing but let me talk about how to
catch a cheater in 2019 or two or how to
cheat like one of the first things I
think is the funniest not funny sorry
but it is kind of funny how people are
it is funny all your fun okay it can be
yeah on your phone you have like the
Notes app if you have an iPhone no
people are cheating through the notes
you can actually talk to people from
your neck you can share notes so like if
you go into your phone and she it's like
the grocery list and it says like tuna
yeah it's code for [ __ ] and she wants
more tuna and the guy is like okay I'll
meet you and I'll whatever yeah and it
looks like her grocery list but she's
sharing its weight on oh yeah you're no
CIA
we are the CIA wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute listen all right
no no you can just share notes and it
will show up in your notes oh it shows
up as a note and you can edit your notes
and they will reflect on their like I
can be texting in Sofia's notes and so
her notes stay the same so if Sofia's
boyfriend looked at it it looks like
she's just typing her grocery list on
her nose how do I was added in you guys
I know you have so much [ __ ] we have so
much intelligence yeah this is the this
is this way this is this generation
sneaky peeky stuff yeah
dad's generation was like no go to a
conference in try to [ __ ] a girl at the
Hilton and if it doesn't work this is my
thing yeah notes
your dad's dead dad's [ __ ] the help
whatever it is if you're chill Etsy you
and I are in a relationship and you're
cheating on me eventually you would
cheat on him by to learn to it ah no no
if I can win I disagree
no I disagree you get there so many
people and [ __ ] and you shoot that [ __ ]
to the gray you take it to the Grange
there's so many people that ask us okay
I actually have a question for you guys
people ask us this so say you're in like
a into like your second year of a
relationship sure and you find out that
they cheated like the first month and
then they never did anybody you're not
you're okay with it okay okay I agree
we're like two old you so we have way
more experience when it comes to right
so it's like you know but I so I know
like a we got those first that like that
doesn't mean she is cheating a reason
for a breakup depends okay depends on
same thing there's a one time ago if the
girl five if a girl [ __ ] like if your
wife if your wife was like am going with
Jenny and her stepdad to [ __ ] another
part she you know she [ __ ] like some
guy randomly and he found out she's like
I was drunk like Aquaman what's my
relationship with Jenny days just your
girl's best friend
do I know Jenny well not really is she
cute we have carbs at the buffet [ __ ]
Jenny would you break up with your girl
over it
no there's such a diatribe a
conversation that has to happen after
the fact of like give me the details I
want to know how this happened and why
this happened and like is it well if I
haven't happen though yeah but there's
more to there's more to relationships
than that than like did you [ __ ] him
because yeah you were [ __ ] horny and
partying and doing out of control or did
you [ __ ] him because like you're not one
to [ __ ] me down yeah this isn't
happening in it yeah true so many
they're so nice there's so much depth to
honorable [ __ ] news you cheated on
now
why do in this game for C it would be
more bummed if she sucked his dick so
weird
so because you gave him satisfaction you
got and you've got hypothetically
nothing even though some women are like
oh I get off on talking tech it's like
no yeah no you don't and you have to go
back left side you know because we have
a juggler you know you know the thing
for music on that's how you know you're
from Utah loophole it's a barrier and
it's not cheating you can't actually you
can use Akane never use a condom
at least coming I dunno in general yeah
wait a minute wait a minute
you're saying so the pupal loophole if
use a condom it's like a barrier and it
wasn't raw dog which means it wasn't you
don't what but don't but doesn't
everyone in New York half the [ __ ]
wear a condom that whole city oh yeah
definitely I mean nobody is using Kyle
because you Connor it doesn't happen by
amount here when you buy them in LA you
have to throw them away right yeah yeah
it sucks but the poop hole loophole yeah
bears are you guys into anal is that why
this came up no that's actually one way
to you can get around cheating yeah but
do you both do anal well we talked about
on the podcast tell me right now we'll
say we have some very interests I'm here
right now real what I'm not gonna say
that because we haven't even done our
anal episodes for you don't brag
week yeah he doesn't like asking us out
like we have our stories we have all the
[ __ ] we want to break we do talk about
on an episode condom poker and there are
certain Chinese girls that you have
condoms like you're like putting like
chairs in like you're right it all for
raw sex and then there are some girls
you know like I cannot [ __ ] around
without it I think you wantem how to
tell like if I you're like I gotta wrap
it up with this one
yeah he got yeah you're like you condom
so we all we've got a lot of guys like
you got a little signs not nobody no
more hot enough if they're definitely
got something yeah no we were just I was
just saying like we give guys a lot of
insight into like [ __ ] that girls we're
trying to give guys insight that like
they don't talk about with their boys
correct I think it's something
embarrassing
okay it's not even embarrassing but like
I'm not gonna be an [ __ ] but there
are so many guys that go into fingering
a girl like holy [ __ ] jack they're still
doing this to jack hammer fan they're
not gonna be like hey guy like well
that's also an issue no not choose Mike
you don't do foreplay all doing like
face I think you should gotta do fingers
and many there's no the big difference
between 20s and 30s okay all right you
don't finger in your 30s okay you know
how to do yes I am with your time you
[ __ ] eat that [ __ ] in that no and
let me tell you wanna get there you want
to get it started you want to start the
bike you gotta you gotta tickle the
[ __ ] click okay yeah you want to get
the [ __ ] wet you rub the clip really
soft when you make out you think you're
right for the ass yeah I was I thought
you were saying in no way you're like
going like this and you're eating
reality no I'm saying like you at some
point are you still using your yeah but
it's like touching you got to be
collection I've got a craigory to finish
shoving fingers in there the jack you
know it's not
don't even like that Aegina hurt yes
like no manners you know what though
there's some like just I know that some
girls while giving a [ __ ] will talk
to fingers in jackhammer your [ __ ]
like do you like that why not Mike what
about when they lick your [ __ ] you
said it in a way that I don't that's not
true like and they shove it up like a
little tickle in the ass can be great
for a guy but you can't [ __ ] rail I
want to dabble or just on the outside do
you like weird like pressure on the
outside like a little bit of leakage on
the okay are you lying
I know do you mean yes you can't get any
near my [ __ ] discussion why because
it's a no-fly zone this urea filthy why
zone you can't go there is a lying
across guys like that so I find that
there are some guys that like love it
and like yeah you the finger and the
eating and then there's some guys
they're like I'm not or some guys like
it and they're trying to repress it
gotta let your lucky gay belching like
so many guys I think it's like Oh anal
sex equates to being gay know if it
feels good there's no sexuality attached
to it if you want it if you feels good
in your ass we talked about it you guys
I'd like to get pegged yeah you can it's
not for getting [ __ ] your girl well
you'd be surprised yeah define pay I'll
put this strap-on on your ass hard no no
no no with like a finger and some like
ass eating yeah I'm definitely okay and
you can't okay that's fine look I say
this you have a women have pretty mouths
okay it doesn't need to go where I poop
well you're diggers don't poop okay I
know your poop just disappears God never
happened and our buttholes are
exponentially dirtier than your
regardless because we have hair even if
we just got on the shower more into my
body versus you out that she'd be doing
that
why do you yeah why do I want to kiss
her mouth I think you're respectful have
Wi-Fi but I think it's kind of nice and
a girl's a little nasty with it yeah no
button it but nasty is like nasty is
like let's do dirty [ __ ] like what's
dirty the leakage just like a finger
near I mean ya know you don't want any
pressure down dirty to you I it's the
role play of thinking he's [ __ ] a
stepmom that's what he likes how we're
on the same page hey good no no I don't
have a stepmom okay um what's ready to
you I'm just saying like dirty raw
uninhibited set usually it's me doing
dirty stuff okay usually it's me like
you you like sucking your day what sort
of it doesn't really take it that dirty
how dirty
like anybody I don't consider that dirty
that's just like okay okay oh wow
dirty I like like my bronzer like like
um I don't know what's - I mean I don't
know there's stuff just just no butts up
for me because I've I've tried it I
played with my own [ __ ] when I jerk
off okay I have in the past
how come I got over I tried it a few
times like you come harder no no oh no
no this makes me come harder Oh roll
with that when I'm thinking about
something that really might have okay
what if I edge if I edge I come so
[ __ ] what you're edging while you're
edging means like you get right close to
coming and you either stop for a second
okay or you or you chill it out oh so
you get right to the point of
ejaculation and he's chill yeah and then
you either do something else with the
partner do something Oh like go cook
like a game and I come back to it like
what I go clean up the house come back
with my [ __ ] throbbing no you go right
to the edging is awesome bill you know
about edgy edging is incredible you come
so much harder after you edge because
you get right to the bone ejaculation ah
yeah and then shop and you switch
positions or switch so your mind turns
off for a second from then it's rare in
your back bro then when you do how so I
mean it's gone you're out flat break a
bad break your [ __ ] back everyone
break your back I'm sorry to come out of
your eyeballs like tears have come yeah